a warning tonight from nv energy the
company says an uptick in scams is
really raising some red flags yeah they
say the scammers are actually using new
strategies to get your money christian
casadas joins us live in studio with
what we should be looking out for
christian well brian denise nv energy
says these new scams involve things like
sending money to cvs to pay cash or
providing debit card information over
the phone requests nv energy says they
will never ask for
they're going to the customers and
threatening them to be disconnected and
usually what we're seeing is that
they're its customers in great standings
so they're not aware of our processes
it's a new wave of scams according to nv
energy with the same goal demand
immediate payment the first approach
that they do is that it's a threat we're
going to threaten to turn off your power
and we have a serviceman on route thank
you for calling nb energy we are aware
that customers are receiving calls from
scammers nb energy says they never call
their customers to threaten immediate
disconnection and demand immediate
payment customers at risk of
disconnection receive a 10-day notice on
their power bill then a 48-hour notice
in the mail we do see that they are
targeting our senior citizens they're
targeting our hispanic communities
customers that don't have english as
their first language some of the best
tips to avoid a scam according to the
bbb beware of fake websites do your
research before you buy that item and
remember if the deal looks too good to
be true it probably is it's a financial
gain for the scammers and if you fall
forward they get your money and then
they're off with it so it's really a
financial impact that what we're seeing
they change their tactics
well the better business bureau also
sounding the alarm with online
purchasing scams now becoming one of the
riskiest scam types adding the average
amount lost is about 750 dollars pets
and pet supply sales also on the radar
they say consumers just need to be aware